NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
LONGTIME TRUMP ADVISOR ROGER
STONE WAS ARRESTED ON FRIDAY BY
FEDERAL AGENTS AND CHARGED WITH
SEVEN FELONIES.
NONE OF THE CHARGES HAD ANYTHING
TO DO WITH RUSSIAN COLLUSION OR
ELECTION MEDDLING, BUT YOU'D
NEVER KNOW THAT FROM THE
PENALTIES HE FACES.
IF CONVICTED, STONE COULD DIE IN
PRISON.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON SEEMS TO
FIND THAT PUNISHMENT EXCESSIVE.
MANY HAVE CHEERED IT.
OFFICIALLY STONE WAS CHARGED
WITH LYING, SOME OF MOST OF OUR
POLITICAL ELITE ENGAGE IN EVERY
DAY.
HIS REAL CRIME WAS FLAMBOYANCE.
STONE HAS SPENT THE LAST 40
YEARS GIVING THE FINGER TO THE
PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
IN THE END, THEY GOT HIM.
THEY ALWAYS DO.
STONE'S ARREST IS ALREADY FADING
FROM THE HEADLINES WERE PLACED
BY THE LATEST POLITICAL CRISIS
IN THE MOMENT OR A SKIRMISH IN
THE CULTURE WARS.
SOON WE WILL FORGET IT EVER
HAPPENED.
BEFORE WE DO, IT'S WORTH TAKING
JUST A MOMENT TO CONSIDER A FEW
BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT IT IF ONLY
BECAUSE NOBODY ELSE IS GOING TO.
FIRST, WHY DID THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT STAGED WHAT WAS IN
EFFECT A MILITARY ASSAULT ON
ROGER STONE'S HOUSE?
STONE HIMSELF ASKED THAT
QUESTION OVER THE WEEKEND.
WATCH.
>> THE IDEA THAT A 29 MEMBER
S.W.A.T. TEAM IN FULL TACTICAL
GEAR WITH ASSAULT WEAPONS WOULD
SURROUND MY HOUSE AND I WOULD
OPEN THE DOOR LOOKING DOWN THE
BARREL OF ASSAULT WEAPONS, THAT
I WOULD BE FROG MARCHED OUT
FRONT BAREFOOT AND HANDCUFFED
WHEN THEY SIMPLY --
CONTACTED ME.
>> AS YOU KNOW, IT'S PRETTY
STANDARD FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: IT'S PRETTY
STANDARD, AS YOU KNOW.
BUT IS IT PRETTY STANDARD?
TO SEND DOZENS OF FEDERAL AGENTS
WITH RIFLES TO ARREST AN UNARMED
66-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO'S BEEN
CHARGED WITH A NONVIOLENT CRIME?
WELL, NO, IT IS NOT STANDARD.
IT IS SHOCKING.
ANY HONEST PERSON WHO PAYS
ATTENTION COULD TELL YOU THAT.
ROGER STONE, WHO WAS THERE, SAYS
THERE WERE 29 AGENTS ON THE
SCENE, ALONG WITH 17 VEHICLES,
TWO OF THEM ARMORED, AND A
HELICOPTER OVERHEAD.
IF THAT'S AN ACCURATE
ACCOUNTING, IT MEANS THE FEDS
TENT MORE ARMED MEN TO ROGER
STONE'S HOUSE IN FORT LAUDERDALE
DONATED TO USAMA BIN LADEN'S
COMPOUND IN PAKISTAN, JUST FOR
SOME PERSPECTIVE ON THIS.
WHAT WAS THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
DOING THAT?
PROSECUTORS KNEW STONE WAS NOT A
FLIGHT RISK.
HE'S BROKE.
HE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE A VALID
PASSPORT.
THEY COULD SIMPLY HAVE CALLED
HIS LAWYER AND TOLD HIM TO
SURRENDER.
THAT'S THE ACTUAL STANDARD IN
CASES LIKE THIS.
BUT THEY DIDN'T DO THAT.
INSTEAD THEY WENT WITH GUNS
DRAWN.
WHO DECIDED TO DO THAT?
HOW MUCH DID IT COST TAXPAYERS?
WE SPEND THE LAST FEW DAYS
TRYING TO ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS.
IT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT
CONTEMPORARY AMERICA THAT WE
COULDN'T.
WE STILL HAVE AN IDEA.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULDN'T
ANSWER US.
THE WHITE HOUSE WHICH SUPPOSEDLY
OVERSEES THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
DIDN'T EVEN RESPOND.
MAYBE THEY DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THOSE QUESTIONS.
POSSIBLE.
THEY DON'T CONTROL ROBERT
MUELLER.
NOBODY CONTROLS ROBERT MUELLER.
MUELLER CAN SEND ARMED MEN TO
YOUR HOME TO ROUST YOU FROM BED
AT GUNPOINT BECAUSE HE FEELS
LIKE IT AND THERE'S NOTHING YOU
OR ANYONE ELSE CAN DO ABOUT IT.
MUELLER HAS AN UNLIMITED BUDGET
AND NO TIMETABLE.
HE DOESN'T HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
HE CAN DO WHATEVER HE WANTS
WHENEVER HE WANTS TO WHOMEVER HE
WANTS.
HE CANNOT BE FIRED.
MUELLER IS THE SINGLE MOST
POWERFUL PERSON IN AMERICA AND
YET NOBODY VOTED FOR HIM.
HE IS A LIVING REBUKE TO THE
PRINCIPLES OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM.
AT THE SAME TIME, OUR LEADERS
TELL US WE NEED ROBERT MUELLER,
ALL-POWERFUL UNELECTED
PROSECUTOR ACCOUNTABLE TO NO ONE
TO PROTECT US FROM THREATS TO
YOU, YOURSELF, HERE DEMOCRACY.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON CATCHES THE
IRONY OF THIS.
MUELLER HIMSELF IS A THREAT TO
OUR DEMOCRACY, THE MOST POWERFUL
MAN ELECTED BY NOBODY.
OUR MEDIA DON'T ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANY OF THIS OR EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT IS A
QUESTION.
THEY HAVE CHOSEN SIDES.
HERE'S ROGER STONE FROM OUR SHOW
ON FRIDAY NIGHT.
>> IT'S DISCONCERTING THAT CNN
WAS AWARE THAT I WOULD BE
ARRESTED BEFORE MY LAWYERS WERE
INFORMED.
SO THAT'S DISTURBING.
IF IT WAS A DANGEROUS SITUATION,
WHICH WOULD MERIT THE S.W.A.T.
TEAM, WELL THEN CNN'S CAMERAMAN
WOULD BE IN DANGER.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WOULD BE
ALLOWED TO BE THERE.
>> Tucker: SO THAT'S A FAIR
QUESTION ABOUT WHO ASKS IT AND
MANY BEGAN ASKING WITHIN MINUTES
OF STONES ARREST ON FRIDAY
MORNING.
HOW DID CNN KNOW ABOUT A RAID
THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE SECRET?
DID THEY LEARN FROM MUELLER'S
TEAM?
CNN REACTED ANGRILY TO THE
QUESTION.
WE ARE REPORTERS, THEY SAID.
WE ARE NOT STATE MEDIA.
WE DIDN'T COLLUDE WITH THE FEDS.
WE USED REPORTERS INTUITION.
YESTERDAY CNN PRESIDENT JEFF
STOCKER DISPATCHED HIS MINIONS
TO BAT DOWN FURTHER QUESTIONS ON
THE TOPIC.
SPEAK ON THE FRINGES OF THE
RIGHT, A CONSPIRACY THEORY
SPREAD AND IT WAS ABOUT CNN AND
ROBERT MUELLER.
THAT WE WERE TIPPED OFF BY
MUELLER.
>> TO EMBARRASS ROGER STONE AND
RECORD HIS ARREST.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT IT'S
PROPAGANDA.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, INCLUDING SOME
MAINSTREAM COMMENTATORS AND
JOURNALISTS, STARTED ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
AS JOURNALISTS, WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL NOT TO ALLOW
BAD-FAITH ACTORS TO HIJACK THE
CONVERSATION MOVE THE STORY AWAY
FROM WHAT IT REALLY SHOULD BE.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
SAVE THAT TAPE.
IT'S ONE FOR THE AGES.
IT SUMMARIZES EVERYTHING.
JUST TO RECAP WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD.
WE JOURNALISTS, SAYS CNN, NEED
TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST THE
"FRINGES OF THE RIGHT" WHO JUST
WANT TO "MOVE THE STORY AWAY
FROM WHAT IT SHOULD REALLY BE."
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING CNN
DECIDES.
THEY DECIDE WHAT THE STORY
SHOULD REALLY BE, AND IF YOU
DON'T AGREE, YOU ARE ON THE
FRINGES OF THE RIGHT.
IN OTHER WORDS, SHUT UP, YOU
GUYS.
STOP ASKING QUESTIONS WE DON'T
FEEL LIKE ANSWERING.
BUT THE SHOW PERSISTED BECAUSE
IT'S OUR JOB.
WE ASKED CNN'S OFFICIAL
SPOKESMAN AND THE KID THAT YOU
STOP PLAYING MEDIA REPORTER A
VERY SUBTLE QUESTION.
DID MUELLER'S OFFICE HELP YOU
WITH YOUR STORY?
THE RESPONSE OF COURSE, FEIGNED
OUTRAGE.
HOW DARE YOU?
YOU ARE RIGHT WING.
BE QUIET.
BUT WHEN WE KEPT PRESSING THEM,
AN INTERESTING THING HAPPENED.
THEY DIDN'T DENY IT.
TO BE TOTALLY CLEAR, HERE'S THE
SPECIFIC QUESTION THAT WE ASKED.
"IN FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS CONFIRM THE RAID ON
ROGER STONE'S HOUSE TO CNN
BEFORE IT HAPPENED?"
VERY SIMPLE QUESTION.
WHEN WE PRESSED IT, CNN DROPPED
THE FAKE OUTRAGE.
THEY JUST REFUSED TO ANSWER.
BECAUSE OF COURSE CNN TALKED TO
MUELLER'S PEOPLE BEFORE THE
RAID.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY DOUBT ABOUT
THAT.
ALL THE BARKING ASIDE, MUELLER
WANTED THE RAID ON ROGER STONE'S
HOME CAUGHT ON TAPE AND PUBLICLY
AIRED AS A WARNING TO OTHER
DISOBEDIENT WITNESSES ABOUT WHAT
CAN HAPPEN TO YOU IF YOU STEP
OUT OF LINE.
CNN WAS HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
CNN ACTED AS THE PUBLIC
RELATIONS ARM OF THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION AS THEY HAVE
BEFORE, AND THEN THEY LIED ABOUT
IT IN THE MOST SELF-RIGHTEOUS
POSSIBLE WAY AND SENT THOSE KIDS
ON TV TO LIE SOME MORE.
IT ANSWERS A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
NO WONDER CNN SEEMS SO EAGER TO
DEFEND FRIDAY'S RAID AND TO
BELITTLE AND ATTACK AND
MARGINALIZE ANYONE WHO ASKED